and we know that there are issues
recruiting and retaining teachers in our
schools that one in five quit in the
first two years so what's your plan to
tackle that
says a massive problem especially
because we know that teacher equality is
the most important factor in driving
outcomes for children and young people
where it comes to what happens within
school that's why I'm setting out
Labor's plans to make sure that we are
supporting people into teaching we do
face this real crisis but more
importantly that we keep them there I
think the best recruitment strategy is a
really strong retention strategy so
we'll introduce
new payments for early career teachers
when they complete their training will
reform the very complicated landscape
that exists at the moment with some of
those wider payments but also labor will
insist that all new teachers coming into
teaching will have to have qualified
teacher status I'll be working towards
it for me this is about sending a really
important signal that we value and
respect the work of our teachers we know
it's an incredibly skilled job and I
want to reset that relationship between
government and the profession so it's a
one-off payment uh just how much is it
again so it'll be in total 15 million
pounds paid for by ending the tax breaks
and private schools so two two thousand
four hundred pounds for the individual
teacher right
um I understand you know the issues that
you have in trying to keep people in the
profession but it's experienced in
senior teachers who've experienced the
biggest fall in real terms pay down 13
from 2010 according to the ifs so once
you give them a pay rise it's a
complicated picture in terms of why
people are leaving I don't think there's
one particular measure that will address
everything but where it comes to what
I've set out around changes on workload
on ofsted on better support within our
schools around mental health there are a
lot of the big challenges that school
leaders and more experienced staff in
particularly with me my question was
will you give experienced teachers a pay
rise under the last Labor government
experience teaches all teachers saw
sustained pay risers they haven't seen
them 13 years ago they're asking what
you do now would you give them a pay
rise now well I think if you compare and
contrast our record from last time
around with the record of the
conservatives which is a 13 real terms
peer cut for teachers on average over
the course of the last decade but the
economy isn't a part of State the
conservatives crashed the economy they
were incredibly reckless in the approach
that they took we're committed to being
serious about the negotiations that we
would have in getting to a better
position all teachers I believe deserve
a fair fair kind of support Fair pay for
the work they do but also to be
recognized for their incredible
professionalism and the pair everybody
is recommended that teachers get a 6.5
pay rise next year so would a labor
government accept that well that's what
we understand to be the case but the
government won't publish the independent
peer review bodies report I want to see
it I think teachers deserve to see it
school leaders who are trying to plan
their budgets for September
urgently need of course you want to see
it everyone wants to see it I want to
see it the viewers want to say it would
you accept a 6.5 pay rise for teachers
well we're speculating on what we're
thinking about okay well my question is
except a 6.5 pay rise I would say that
as the starting point for negotiation we
can't get anywhere unless we're prepared
to negotiate we I understand that I
understand it what does that mean
they're everything point for negotiation
does that mean you would want to give
them more than 6.5 does that mean you
want to I just don't understand what
does that mean as I understand it there
have been non-serious negotiations led
by the Secretary of State since April so
it's a little wonder that we're facing
further strike action this week because
she won't talk to them she won't publish
the report and she want to speak to the
teaching unions I will be talking to
them trying to find a way through it
resolving issues around pay resolving
issues around workload and what I'm
setting out this week is a really
ambitious plan for how we respect and
appreciate teachers for what they're
doing give them better ongoing
professional development and more
support for early career teachers with
that new retention payment all paid for
by ending the tax breaks on private
schools
so would I I'm sorry that I keep feel
like you probably feel like I just keep
going on about this but the reason is
because I don't really understand the
answer that you're giving me would labor
accept a 6.5 payers for teachers well I
want to see the report we all want to
see the report
I'm just asking a straight question 6.5
for teachers I'm not going to come on
this program and commit to a figure I
wouldn't expect the Secretary of State
to do that either that is what will
happen during the course of a
negotiation where you will arrive at a
position that everyone can live with so
I wouldn't expect the Secretary of State
to be committing to that number what I
do expect the Secretary of State to be
doing I think what any sensible and
credible government would be doing would
be trying to find a way through the
impasse publishing the report committing
to talks getting serious about it not
constantly belittling teachers picking
fights in newspapers and focusing on
peripheral narrow issues the most
important thing that parents want to
know right now is is the teacher in
front of my child's class qualified are
they properly supported for what they're
doing and can we get these strikes to
come to an end in principle should the
government accept the pay review
recommendations well they've said that
they will previously so we'll wait and
see what happens we take that seriously
I'm asking you know in principle should
a government accept the pay review
recommendation that is normally what
happens yes that is normally what takes
place
um what we're seeing at the moment is
far from the normal kind of process so
when you've got a government that has
received these reports won't publish the
reports I think it's incredibly
disrespectful we're almost at the end of
the summer term School leaders want to
plan on that basis they don't know what
their budgets are going to be we need a
different kind of relationship it has to
involve respecting teachers for what
they're doing we're not always going to
agree with them about how much you've
given well they're not pay risers if I
was Secretary of State I would
absolutely be straight about that but
we're not in government at the moment
when we are in government if we win the
trust of the British people they will
have an honest straightforward
relationship with me we won't always
agree but I'll be around that table so
you can get to work it out and get to a
better position that is what our
children deserve not this ridiculous
politicking that we see from the Tories
teachers are striking for two more days
next week disruptive for pupils
disruptive of course for parents as well
do you support The Strokes it is
incredibly disruptive I don't want the
strikes to happen most of the teachers
I've spoken to recently when visiting
schools tell me the last thing they ever
imagined when they became a teacher was
going out on strike and in some cases
this is the first time in their career
that very experienced teachers are
taking strike action but there is still
time for the Secretary of State to
commit to talks to publish the report
and then hopefully those strikes could
be averted and I want to talk to you a
little bit on Child Care a big big issue
for so many people of course what's
Labor's offer on Child Care uh we'll be
setting up more later this week as part
of the mission that I'll be launching
with Kia around the importance of making
sure all of our children get a great
start in life my position is that I want
to deliver a reformed and modern child
care system from the end of Parental
leave to the end of primary school the
first step I've set out around that is
breakfast clubs for every Primary School
child in England that would make a
massive difference during the cost of
living crisis for parents but also for
children all of the evidence is really
clear that you get better outcomes for
children when you have that started to
the day in an interview at the Sunday
Times in January you said that the scale
and ambition of your child care reforms
will be like the creation of the NHS and
they reported it saying that you wanted
to guarantee child care for all parents
of children aged 9 months to 11 years
are you going to do that for all her
children and parents or are you going to
mean to test it I've got to make sure
that there are child care places
available right across our country which
is not the situation at the moment that
we can't provide it's a really and just
trying to find out what the policy is if
that's okay are you going to guarantee
child care for all parents of children
at age nine months 11 years or you're
going to mean to test that what I was
talking about was the permanent shift
that we need to see where we treat
earlier as education and child care as
an integral part of our education system
that is the permanent shift that I want
to see on a scale with the NHS because
what we have in this country is early as
education somewhere over here not
integral to the education system that is
very different from most of the European
countries alongside that making sure
that when we're putting more money into
the system the government did did
respond to what the pressure that we've
been applying and put more money into
the system at the budget that gives us a
better baseline from which to build a
better system that will support parents
and actually a real focus on quality of
the provision because I want to make
sure that particularly our most
Advantage children get a really good
start in life at the moment lots of
those children are not accessing
earlier's education you see I know how
passionate you are About Childcare and
you know about the impact it has on
children or mothers as well perhaps from
your own experience I'm just trying to
work out
you know what happened to these reforms
did Rachel Reeves get on the phone and
say look you've got to scale this back
we can't fool this what actually
happened nothing has you know nothing
has happened in that in that way I'm
absolutely determined to deliver early
as education and child care reform it is
a major priority for me it will be a big
priority for the next Labor government
and I know it is for Rachel too she
spoken about the importance quite
rightly of the economic impact of women
moving out of work or cutting back on
their hours because Child Care isn't
there but alongside that I want to see a
real focus on making sure that all of
our children get a really really great
start in life but we have to be aware of
every every part of what we've set out
so far has been fully funded and fully
costed and that will be continued to be
our position but we have we will if the
net if we do happen to form the next
Labor government if we're so fortunate
that the people British people trust us
we will face an incredibly difficult
fiscal inheritance because the
conservatives have trashed the economy
and that will present us with some
really tough choices there's one other
story that you you want to get your
reaction to um Catherine bubble Singh
who is the head teacher of the very high
achieving School Michaela in Brent in
London She's accused Your Shadow cabinet
colleague Jess Phillips of racism after
a bit of a Twitter route and she's
written to kirst armor to say her
behavior is a clear example of
unconscious bias I mean that she hates
me despite not knowing me because she
subscribes to the idea that black and
Asian individuals in public life owe a
duty to voice opinions that match with a
left-wing view of the world or they are
worthy of her contempt
your reaction to this my reaction to
anyone who feels unhappy about the
conduct of a labor MP is that they
should complain through our processes
and then that the matter can be looked
into and as members of parliament were
also subject to a code of conduct in
Parliament as well and there are
processes in place for people who are
unhappy with an MPS Behavior to report
it in that way I would suggest that to
any individual that's unhappy about the
conduct of a member of parliament so she
thinks you think it's right for her to
put in an official Complaint about this
I think anyone who is unhappy about the
conduct of an MP in any way
um should should make their concerns
known and then they can be properly
considered do you think Jess Phillips is
racist that's no I don't
um but I think it's important that if
people have concerns if they're unhappy
about the conduct of a member of
Parliament that can be investigated as
part of that process
and just on the wider Point as well and
it feels like Catherine babelsing feels
that she is being I guess penalized or
used as a bit of a lightning rod because
she's not doesn't have a left-wing view
of the world and that many people in the
teaching profession and Leadership roles
in teaching I guess she would say do do
you think there's any truth in that when
I visit schools the length and breadth
of the country what I find are dedicated
to people who are focused on making sure
children get a great start in life very
rarely will the conversation drift into
into politics what people come into
teaching to do and what people uh you
know when they become School leaders are
focused on as well is delivering really
high quality educations and that's
that's as it should be would you like to
visit the school that she runs I love I
visit schools everywhere I'm always open
to invitations to visit schools right
across the country it's the best part of
the job okay thank you very much thank
you